[Applause]
[Music]
February is upon us in the month of love
is full of video games that want your
attention whether you're into tactics
action or making your own thing there's
probably something you'll want to play
this month this episode of new releases
takes a top-level look at February so
let's dive into some of the hottest
games launching all month long let's hit
that tactical game first with the Dark
Crystal Age of resistance tactics as the
name says this game is all about
crafting strategies to help the gelfling
defeat the evil Skeksis based on the
Netflix adaptation of the cult classic
movie this game features over 50
skirmishes to win 14 characters to lead
into battle and plenty of custom jobs to
assign along the way Age of resistance
charges on the ps4 Xbox one PC and
switch on Tuesday February 4th one week
later the Yakuza remastered collection
expands with Yakuza 5 let me explain the
collection is a one-time purchase that
gets you remasters of Yakuza three four
and five those games just happen to have
staggered release dates taking after the
five in the name this particular entry
is set across five different parts of
Japan and features five playable
characters including everyone's favorite
ruffian Kazuma Kiryu it's coming
exclusively to ps4 on Tuesday the 11th
that's not the only ps4 exclusive coming
this month either Dreamz is the latest
creative endeavor from LittleBigPlanet
creators Media Molecule
featuring a toolset that lets you build
anything you can well dream up you can
craft all sorts of platforming
adventures shoot them up stages and so
much more I've even seen somebody
recreate Final Fantasy 7 you can make
your dreams come true on Valentine's Day
Friday the 14th just don't let your
dreams turn into night terrors
uh sorry about I was just resting my
eyes the next game we have to talk about
is actually two and one it's the
bayonetta and vanquish 10th anniversary
bundle it's been 10 years since these
two platinum games cult classics
launched and this package Gussie's up
the games with 4k resolution and 60fps
support for those of you with a ps4 pro
or xbox 1x if you missed out on the
original releases this seems like the
best way to revisit them the bundle
comes to ps4 and Xbox one on Tuesday the
18th the month closes out with even more
action that should make anime fans happy
one punch man a hero nobody knows is an
arena fighting game based on the hit
series with a very interesting gameplay
hook the fights are three on three but
if you pick Saitama himself he'll show
up late leaving you at a disadvantage
until he arrives if both sides pick the
invincible hero they can hurt each other
but neither will flinch of course there
are plenty of other fan favorite
fighters to choose from too one punch
man hits ps4 Xbox one and PC on Friday
the 28th and those are some of the
hottest games launching all month long
as always remember that release dates
are based on retailer listings and are
subject to change thanks for watching
guys and I'll be back next Sunday with a
closer look at more February games